احنا دلوقت معنا الاستاذ محمود مؤسس
المبادره بس قبل اي حاجه انا بجد المبادره
دي انا حسيت فيها بالمعنى الحقيقي للتكاتف
الاجتماعي في ظل اي ظرف صعب ممكن يكون
بيمر به العالم كله ان اا يتم تخصيص يوم
اا معين علشان يعلم الشباب الحرف ده لا
علاقه انتشار واسع جدا جدا همم في
المحافظه فوق ما انت ممكن تتخيلي ده
يكلمني اكثر عنه الاستاذ محمود صباح الخير
صباح الخير يا فندم حضرتكم همم الحمد لله
رب العالمين انا انسان بسيط مؤمن همم دوري
بالمشاركه الشعبيه الفعاله ف- همم بسبب
تواجدي على الارض ك- صاحب محل حلاقه
فبتتعامل مع كل فئات الشعب وكل الاقمار
الصنيه ومحل الحلاقه دوت بيبقى اي مكان
للفضه واللي عنده مشكله بيحب يقولها عند
الحلاق ويتكلم معه وانا من النوع اللي
بيحب يسمع في وقت الناس ما بتسمعش فيه
يعني كل اللي عاوز يتكلم لا انا بسمع
الانسان
عايزين نتعلموا حاجه
طبعا في زر الظروف اللي احنا بنمر بيها
العالم كله يعني فالناس كلها ال- ال- ال-
اللي بيتكلم في
البطوله الاسعار الغاليه اللي عاوز يزود
دخله فالمشاكل ديت كلها في الشباب في
الاقمار الصنانيه كلها فانا باتكلم معهم
الحمد لله في اي مش مشكله وكده حتى عشان
كده صموا المحل بتاعي الصالون الشعبي همم
خدمه المواطنين الحمد لله رب العالمين
وكده فانا قلت ايه الشباب طب ايه ايه اللي
عاوز يتعلم صنعه او كده ف- همم
تخش فيه قال لي احنا جربنا ودخلنا
اكاديميات وكده كثير وكانت بمبالغ عاليه
وفي الاخر بيتعلمش سنه ولا حاجه بياخذ
شهاده بس اكثر
فكره المباراه
عندي قلت ابدا برده بنفسي يعني اللي يجيء
يتدرب عندي يطلع صنيه شاطر ادي له كل
خبايا الصنعه مش ابخل عليه باي حاجه انا
مش جاي همم نظره ادي له لا انا هاجربه
عملي ومن هنا بقى قلت ايه يعني هيطلع من
عندي وانا اللي هاوجه له سوق العمل هي مش
العمليه مش نظريه بس وفي ناس علمتهم
واشتغلوا معك بعد كده
من اول دوره الحمد لله رب العالمين كان
العدد 10 او 12 فرد عشان كده حتى انا ايه
قلت اجرب كنت كان يوم في الاسبوع بس اضرب
واحد او اثنين في المحل لقيت الموضوع برده
زاد وكده طبعا المحل هيبقى زحمه مش هنعرف
نشتغل فيه فكان في سنتر جنب المحل يعني
بعد مني كده فقلت ايه اجر المكان منه همم
عده زيت رحت السنتر فقلت الراجل عاوز اجر
المكان فروحت هاجر المكان منه وبقيتدي
الدوره هناك فلما اعرف صاحب السنتر ان هي
الدوره لما مجانيه حتى هو سال يعني الناس
بجد فلما عرفوا الراجل برده ايه شارك معنا
فلوس وكده والحمد لله من اول دوره همم
وجهنا للخريجين كلهم من الدوره بسوق العمل
ومن ضمنهم شاب اشتغل معي انا شخصيا في ال-
في المحل الحمد لله كان بابريزه عندي
الحمد لله رب العالمين
دورات مجانيه مثل ما يقول محمود معانا سمر
نعملتها في قسم واقتصاد صباح النور
هل تكفيه لمحمود
اللي ياتي من مهنه
الحلاقه للمعيشه اليوميه يعني
كم ولا كيف ولا لا
نسالكم
كم مصدر للرزق
هي سمر في الاستوديو بتسالك هل الدخل اللي
بيدخل لك من حرفه زي الحلاقه كافي للمعيشه
اليوميه الحمد لله رب العالمين
الحمد لله رب العالمين يعني لا الحمد لله
كيفي طبعا زي الفل انا راجل برده متزوج
وفاتح بيه وعندي اولاد الحمد لله الصنعه
ديت همم الحمد لله كل المدربين معنا
لتعليم الحرف كلهم مؤهلات عشان لما شاب
يقول لك لا انا هاشتغل ليه كل المدربين
والصناعه دي هي الحمد لله ما اشتغلتش لا
الحرف دي هي اللي جوزتني وهي الحمد لله رب
العالمين زي الفل الحمد لله رب العالمين
الى جانب كل مهنه لازم يكون عندنا شيء
عمله سايد انا انا شخصيا اصلح كراسي
الحديقه جدا شاطره بهذا الموضوع